20 seconds for ding he needs to make a  move does he know he needs to make a  move  probably just 15.  there he goes  g6 plate oh that looks that's an ugly  move  wrong  yeah  and he's also not thrilled about it  looked like he panicked a little bit  when the seconds were taken down there  yeah let me just hand on his head now  let me just very quickly check what the  computer had to say after fe five well  it says bishop d4 the only way to be  better  wow bishop d4 but we started  bishop takes then  knight to f5  bishop c5 queen c6  uh this is not obvious that the black  king can hide on g6 runs here okay  that's tough  yeah it's not the most obvious move  idea to make the hole on g5 and then  allow white queen to go to d8  no  that's tricky because the first two  moves they're supernatural right uh i  mean they're pretty  straightforward but they are queen c6s